if you want to test a scientific
experiment in zero-g you've got a few
options you could send it to the
International Space Station but that's
expensive and let's be honest it's
unlikely to happen unless you've got a
few friends at a space agency you could
package it up into a small cube sat and
launch it but that's still pretty
expensive you could take it along on a
zero-g flight and strap yourself into a
plane that's accelerating towards the
ground just the right speed to cause
weightlessness but that's still a lot of
hassle and a lot of expense and a lot of
fuel burned but fortunately there is
another option this is the drop tower at
the University of Bremen in Germany
inside is an enormous vacuum chamber the
last 90 minutes powerful pumps have been
removing all the air from inside turning
it into a near vacuum that's perfect for
freefall experiments and there's a drop
capsule about ready to go in this
experiment I try to study the charge
separation process through tribal
charging the effect that causes static
electricity during the microgravity
glass beats are released into a
capacitor in microgravity you have
enough time to trace your particles and
you can observe other interesting
effects that aren't observable in normal
gravity acceleration due to gravity on
earth is roughly 10 meters per second
per second and without air resistance to
slow things down that drop capsule is
going to start moving very quickly
indeed in the first second after release
the drop capsule goes 10 meters next
second 20 next second 30 next second 40
and then we've used up pretty much all
the height there is to get just one more
seconds with a freefall you would have
to build this tower half as high again
unless you something really clever and
start by going up the experiments are
installed into a drop vehicle that's the
experiment itself it's all the
measurement and diagnostic tools it's a
computer controlling it we throw it
upwards with up to almost 30 G for 200
milliseconds and then in
0g4 almost 10 seconds in and the
deceleration finally by the end of the
experiment has a value of about 35 to
maximum 50 G it should be very accurate
because you can imagine if the energies
is too large then we would hit the
ceiling we would destroy our power
vacuum containment which is the most
delicate element we have in our hours we
almost perfectly balanced the the center
of gravity to the vertical axis of the
capsule by adjusting some counter
weights at appropriate locations in the
capsule the experiments are in fluid
mechanics it's in combustion it's in
fluid handling it's in biotechnology
it's in physics and astrophysics it's in
fundamental physics so almost almost any
disciplines it's a little
counterintuitive but the capsule really
is weightless all the way up and all the
way down the forces acting on it remain
the same even as it changes direction
relative to us so here we go launch time
the slingshot will fire and in the 9
seconds at the capsules in freefall an 8
meter deep pit filled with polystyrene
pellets will slide in over the catapult
to catch the capsule hopefully
thank you everyone at the University of
Bremen of the drop tower and to all the
researchers who are testing here today
pull down the description for more links
about them and about their work